you wrote an article two years ago
titled when the world seems like one big
conspiracy
how understanding the structure of
global cabal theories Can Shed light on
their Allure and their inherent
falsehood
what are Global cabal theories and why
do so many people believe them 37 of
Americans for example well the the
global cabal Theory it has many
variations but basically there is a
small group of people a small cabal that
secretly controls everything that is
happening in the world all the Wars all
the revolutions all the epidemics
everything that is happening is
controlled by this very small group of
people who are of course evil and have
bad intentions
and this is this is a very well-known
story that it's not new it's been there
for thousands of years it's very
attractive
uh because first of all it's simple
you don't you don't understand
everything that happens in the world you
just need to understand one thing though
in Ukraine the Israeli Palestinian
conflict 5G technology covid-19 it's
simple there is this Global cabal they
do all of it and also it enables you uh
to shift all the responsibility to all
the bad things that is that are
happening in the world today's small
cabal it's the Jews it's the Freemason
it's not us
and also it creates it it creates this
fantasy utopian fantasy if we only get
rid of the small cabal we solved all the
problems of the world salvation the
Israeli Palestinian conflict the one in
Ukraine the epidemics poverty everything
is solved just by knocking out this
small cabal so and it's simple it's
attractive and this is why so many
people believe it
um it's again it's not new Nazism was
exactly this Nazism began as a
conspiracy theory we don't call Nazism a
conspiracy theory because oh it's a big
thing it's an ideology
but if you look at it it's a conspiracy
theory the basic Nazi idea was the Jews
control the world get rid of the Jews
you solved all the world's problems now
the interesting thing about these kind
of theories again they tell you that
even things that look to be the opposite
of each other actually they are part of
the conspiracy
so in the case of Nazism the Nazis told
people you know you have capitalism and
communism you think that they are
opposite right ah this is what the Jews
want you to think actually the Jews
control both communism Trotsky marks or
Jews blah blah blah and capitalism wrote
the Rothschilds the Wall Street it's all
controlled by the Jews so the Jews are
fooling everybody but actually the
Communists and the capitalists are part
of the same global cabal
and again this is very attractive
because ah now I understand everything
and I also know what to do I just give
power to Hitler he gets rid of the Jews
I solved all the problems of the world
now as a historian the most important
thing I can say about these theories
they are never right
because the global cabal Theory says two
things first everything is controlled by
a very small number of people secondly
these people hide themselves they do it
in secret now both things are nonsense
it's impossible for people to control a
small group of people to control and
predict everything because the world is
too complicated you know you look at a
real world conspiracy conspiracy is
basically just a plan think about the
American invasion of Iraq in 2003.
you had the most powerful superpower in
the world
with the biggest military who is the
biggest intelligence services with the
most sophisticated you know the FBI and
the CIA and all the agents they invade a
third rate
country Third Rate power Iraq with this
idea we'll take over Iraq and we will
control it we'll make a new order in the
Middle East and everything falls apart
their plan completely backfires
everything they hope to achieve they
achieve the opposite America United
States is humiliated they caused the
rise of Isis they wanted to take out
terrorism they created more terrorism
worst of all the big winner of the war
was Iran
you know the United States goes to war
with all its power and gives Iran
a victory on a silver plate the Iranians
don't need to do anything the Americans
are doing everything for them
now this is real history Real History is
when you have it's not a small group of
people a lot of people with a lot of
power carefully planning something
and it goes completely out of uh against
their plan and this we know from
personal experience like every time we
need we try to plan something a birthday
party a surprise birthday party a trip
somewhere things go wrong this is
reality so the idea that a small group
of I don't know the Jewish cabal the
Freemasons whoever they can really
control and predict all the wars this is
nonsense the second thing that is
nonsense is to think they can do that
and still remain Secret
it sometimes happens in history that a
small group of people accumulates a lot
of power if I now tell you that xinjin
ping and the hands of the CCP the
Chinese Communist party they have a lot
of power they control the military the
media are the economy the University of
China this is not a conspiracy theory
this this is obviously everybody knows
it everybody knows it because to gain so
much power you need you usually need
publicity
Hitler could not Hitler gained a lot of
power in Nazi Germany because he had a
lot of publicity if Hitler remained
unknown working behind the scenes he
would not gain power
so the way to gain power is usually
through publicity so secret cabals don't
gain power and even if you gain a lot of
power nobody has the kind of power
necessary to predict and control
everything that happens in the world
every all the time happens
you did not predict and you did not plan
and you did not control
the sad thing is there's usually an
explanation for everything you just said
that involves a a secret Global cabal
that the reason your vacation planning
always goes wrong is because you're not
competent there is a competent small
group
that Ultra competent small group I hear
this with intelligence agencies the CIA
are running everything Mossad is running
everything you'll see I mean as a
historian you get to know how many
blunders these people do all they are so
and they're capable but they're so
incompetent in so many ways again look
at the Russian invasion of Ukraine
Before the War people thought oh Putin
was such a genius and the Russian army
was one of the strongest armies in the
world this is what Putin thought
and it completely backfired with a cabal
explanation there would be there's a
nato-driven United States
military-industrial complex that wants
to create chaos and so they can't put
the gun to put in his head and told him
Vladimir if you don't invade we shoot
you how did they cause put into Infinity
it's the thing about conspiracy theories
is there's usually a way to explain
everything it's not religion you can you
can always find explanation
for everything and you know in the end
it's it's intellectual Integrity if you
insist on whenever people confronted
with evidence with finding some very
very complicated explanation for that
too you can explain everything we know
that it's a question of of of
intellectual integrity and I also say
another thing
um
the conspiracy theories they do get one
thing right certainly in today's world
I think they represent an authentic and
Justified fear of a lot of people that
they are losing control of their lives
they don't understand what is happening
and this is I think is a is not just a
legitimate fear this is an important
fear they are right we are losing
control of Our Lives we are facing
really big dangers but not from a small
cabal of fellow humans
the problem with many of these
conspiracy theories that yes we have a
problem with a new AI technology
but if you now direct the fire against
certain people
so instead of all humans cooperating
against a real common threats whether
it's the rise of AI whether it's a
global warming you're only causing us to
fight each other
and I think that the key question that
people who spread these ideas I mean
many of them they honestly believe it's
not malicious that they honestly believe
in in these theories is do you want to
spread to spend your life spreading hate
uh towards people or do you want to work
on more constructive projects I think
one of the big differences between those
who believe in conspiracy theories
and people who
warn about the dangers of AI the dangers
of climate change
um we don't see certain humans as evil
and hateful the problem isn't humans the
problem is uh something outside Humanity
yes humans are contributed contributing
to the problem but ultimately the enemy
is external to humanity
whereas conspiracy theories usually
claim that a certain part of humanity is
the source of all evil which leads them
to eventually think in terms of
Exterminating
uh this part of humanity
which uh which leads sometimes to
historical disasters like Nazism so it
can lead to Haber can also lead to a
like cynicism apathy that basically says
it's not in my power to make the world
better so you don't actually take action
I think it is within the power of every
individual to make the world a little
bit better you know you can't do
everything don't try to do everything
find one thing in your areas of activity
a place where you have some agency and
try to do that and hope that other
people do their bit and if everybody do
their bit will will manage and if if we
don't we don't but at least we try